merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame an porunach ministre
de la transition
énergétique nos concitoyens nos
industriels nos entreprises ont
lourdement été éprouvé par la flambé des
prix de l'électricité en
2022 face à cette crise le gouvernement
et la majorité ont été au rendez-vous
pour protéger les Français comme nul par
ailleurs en Europe grâce à la mise en
place du bouclier tarifaire cependant
l'incompréhension persiste vis-à-vis des
de l'électricité qui apparaissent en
déconnexion avec ceux de notre
production il ne s'agit évidemment pas
ici de remettre en cause la solidarité
européenne au travers de notre marché de
l'électricité comme le propose le
rassemblement national avec démagogie et
irresponsabilité sans cette solidarité
nous n'aurions pas tenu face à la crise
il s'agit de défendre des prix sur le
long terme qui nous permettent de
modérer les factures des ménages et des
entreprises en limitant le lien entre
les prix de de l'électricité et ceux du
gaz dans ce contexte la France a été à
l'avant-garde de ce combat en défendant
une réforme du marché européen et de
l'électricité c'est aujourd'hui un
succès que nous pouvons saluer cela a
permis de faire comprendre à nos voisins
allemands que la compétitivité notre
entreprise nucléaire était un avantage
pour l'ensemble des européens la France
a supporté une parole forte et fédérée
autour d'elle un certain nombre de pays
au sein d'une alliance du nucléaire pour
défendre l'intérêt des consommateurs C
cet accord EUR est donc une victoire
française dont nous pouvons être fi
c'est aussi une victoire européenne car
nous renforçons notre compétitivité
vis-à-vis des États-Unis C enfin est
surtout une victoire pour le climat car
cet accord facilitera les
investissements dans la production
d'énergie décarbonée pouvez-vous madame
la ministre nous indiquer quelles seront
les prochaines étapes de négociation et
ce que peuvent espérer les Français pour
leur facture d'électricité je vous en
remercie merci la parole est à Madame
agè panier runacher ministre de la
transition énergétique
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
luqué avec cet accord sur le marché de
l'électricité la France obtient une
victoire majeure comme vous l'avez très
bien souligné c'est une victoire de
l'Europe qui affirme sa puissance
économique face à la concurrence de la
Chine et à l'inflation reduction Act
américain c'est une victoire pour la
France et pour les Français avec
un traitement identique entre le
nucléaire et les énergies renouvelables
c'est aussi une victoire pour le climat
car les investissements dans les
énergies décarboné seront facilité une
victoire enfin celle du bon sens et
celle de la raison je vousadresse à vous
celle du bon sens et celle de la raison
face à l'extrême droite et l'extrême
gauche qui n'ont cessé de prener le
repli sur soi et la sortie du marché
européen car à quoi aurait mené le
projet que vous avez proposé la semaine
dernière messieurs de l'extrême droite
dans votre proposition largement décrié
sur l'ensemble de ces bancs à augmenter
massivement la facture d'électricité des
Français à mettre en grave difficulté
les industriels et apporter atteinte à
notre sécurité d'approvisionnement au
contraire avec cet accord nous
déconnectons les prix du gaz et
l'électricité c'était une promesse nous
la tenons nous empêchons l'envolet des
prix de l'électricité dans les crise
nous stabilisons les prix de
l'électricité sur le long terme pour les
industriels et pour les Français nous
sécurisons notre approvisionnement voilà
en d'autres termes comme l'a dit le
président de la République nous
reprenons le contrôle sur le prix de
l'électricité cet accord il est le fruit
de la vision de l'exigence que porte le
président de la République pour l'Union
européenne le travail que j'ai mené avec
l'Alliance Européenne pour le nucléaire
et également avec la commission euréne a
payé cette étape est maintenant franchie
nous allons conclure en trilogue avec le
Parlement européen et nous tiendrons la
présence la promesse
président la parole est àadame